hello everyone we have young hercules
here in the studio thank you very much
for coming to be here with us
no thanks to italy an excellent player
with a great career how are you doing
well very happy to be back
home i'm from las vegas it always feels nice
to return and more for a
massive event like what the disc is, the
final is coming this Wednesday inside the stadium
of león line the león club versus
seattle sounders that we hope to see well
I think that a very attractive duel we are
talking about two very important teams
in their league  two winning teams it will
be very difficult to find a team like
the constant and regular lion that is
leonel liga mx in the last 23 years and
in the other way a team as
constant regular them járol saunders
iron saunders who are always in
finals are always competing  they have already
won 2 in the last 5 years any
tournament that participates in the hoops anders
they take it seriously they want to win it is a
team that  He always creates references
within the Major League Soccer league,
great players, a great technician in
branch matters, a very
serious organization and from León, in the same way, the
Martínez family of the owners of the lion
have done things in a very good way
since the lion ascended.  It's been a long
time and everything
that León has won is two of the
most serious teams in what is Mexico and
what is Major League Soccer.
You played for the MS.
It's better to admit it, but hey, better
American,
I already knew
what I would say are some of the
differences between these two leagues.
Natalia has changed a lot because
eight or ten years ago she played with A. I can
tell you that the difference was very marked
tactically in the type of football she creates
for putting liga mx to what was major
league soccer the presence of one
another today so much
player exchange we see every day more players from
liga mx major league soccer more
mid-range players what a good mx league
we see the resources that mx line has
the resources that milic soccer has are
two very attractive leagues I think the
differences are still money
because the kiss me league is a lot of money a
lot of money  People do not realize the
type of money that Mexico has,
that Liga MX has, the economic power it
has and the limitations that you
league soccer have in that aspect, the cap on
franchise player salary, mechanisms
that do not allow the same amount to be hired.
that a
Mexican team but we see some teams in
major league soccer as usually happens
to the sounders or atlanta their from the galaxy that
type of team and since they can
hire many Mexican teams they do not have
that economic power it has changed a
lot but I believe close to what
people think
the m ls is criticized a lot you think they
are at the level of the mx league yet or I
still don't think they lack it and why do
I say that  it lacks it because one has to
win if slicks cop has to win if it
's concachampions it has to win it
well which league usually wins is the
mexican league and that's why when don garber
mentioned that he has some
barbaric inspirations in major league soccer he comes out and
says  That being wants to be one of the
best leagues in the world, raise your hand
those of Mexico, the MX league, but beware,
they are not even the best league in this region
, they have beaten us, they have to win, not
only a penalty of about 15 if they
want us improved  they want to overcome and he is
very right so he is criticized for
the inspirations for suddenly how he
does things in a different way but
we see the growth of a league
yes in its infancy what
major league soccer has done is incredible and for a reason
we always see this type of  events for
something we always see the proximity of the
mx league to major league soccer I think
criticized yes but with just reason the
reason for the aspirations and where
this born in the a  Ángeles criados en
las vegas'
Did you ever imagine our city
with so many sporting events
I never ever growing up the soccer I
could watch was Liga MX television and
96 when mission major league soccer
once came cancer and weezer to
play against him  the colorado rapids and they
played here in las vegas and i went to see
that game it was the closest i
got to professional soccer back
then to think that a city that
had no sport at all suddenly
has nascar soccer with las vegas'
lights  American football with the riders
basket with the sixes be here with
what has been the golden knights
a city that suddenly was pure pure
almost not pure sin as they say now
to be one of the capitals in sports
boxing the ufc is incredible  It's incredible to
see what Las Vegas has done in such a
short time. I'm surprised by what I
saw growing up, but I'm not surprised by
what Las Vegas is, the
second final of the Lix Cap, and they do it.
here in las vegas
why not any other age if i am
a fan who wants a
neutral venue or any venue in the world
to see my team that is not in my
city my favorite team in any
sport well why not las vegas you hardly
go to  find a hotel you will find
nightlife you will find me you
will find the best food in the world
you will find this city has everything
to be a massive event to have a
super bowl type event the superbowl is
a world cup final type event not
there is a better city in the world to get in the
way than las vegas'
that you start that is going to have better
fans for this Wednesday
fans of león practices of 0 who
is going to present themselves keep the law in a very
good question and I am telling you because both
teams are very
regionally popular regionally the lion has a
fantastic fan base and has won a
lot in recent years and the android irons are the
same and they travel in good numbers
but it's going to be a lot  and it is interesting to see if
Mexican pride suddenly touches the
pride of what the midfielder is.
so
who wins it's so difficult to choose a
winner it's 50/50 a coin toss if I have
to choose someone the heart also plays
I played meet the sounders and
I became champion met saunders is
a team that I respect a lot I
respect the Martinez family and they  that he has done
with leon in an immense way but
I do believe for the moment that you live and tree
and the doubts with the game or rather the
international trophy that
the león team has not achieved and
I lean a little more towards the team
say to  the shoulders
marker for how he plays towards role and how
león plays I think it can be or 100
sounders and it will not surprise us the
days between the last minute back
back can be but known returns
where  a team that I make that is
without great figures that continues to show
its great capacity with a team in león
that loves to attack the spaces will
be there the transitions will be
something else and the roles andrés have some
planes in the attack can be  that raúl
ruidíaz another to be the wey
thank you